I know you're a vegan right
yes indeed do you miss anything uh in
terms of the foods I'm a kid from North
Carolina originally so I've had
everything Howard I had bear meat
[ __ ] rabbit God damn wow no I've had
everything and a lot of that [ __ ] I've
had most into a [ __ ] sausage you know
what I'm saying you know sausage and
[ __ ] right so you don't know what it is
it's weird because basically a [ __ ]
snake is a sausage you know what I'm
saying right why kill a snake why to
turn it into sausages
a sausage a moving sausage anyway God
damn you're so right my father was a
hunter you know he didn't let living in
the project stop him from hunting and
hit his long-ass shotgun he would bring
he would bring wild [ __ ] home all the
time put paper it down in the living
room and clean these [ __ ] right
in the [ __ ] living room one time he
caught a deer and they bring that [ __ ]
home could you imagine your dad been
hoisting a [ __ ] deer over his
shoulder and carrying that [ __ ] into the
projects
what [ __ ] antlers and every every
[ __ ] thing like excuse me excuse me
excuse me with the [ __ ]
poking people and [ __ ] a big deer over
his shoulder and unless it upset you
yeah I mean you became a vegan I think
because you love animals I've been a
vegan for six years now and cheese
no cheese no eggs no meat nothing that
blinks and and you know nothing that
breeds I admire that what about protein
though what do you eat for protein my
protein is great Howard I [ __ ]
muscles are [ __ ] great my weight is
perfectly at 180 I don't budge I go if I
may go down one pound or up one pound
that's it Howard wow it's crazy have you
ever had a a carrot [ __ ] hot dog no I
didn't know there was such a thing a
carrot hot dog I'm telling you right now
you take a [ __ ] carrot and you you
soak that [ __ ] overnight in your in
seasonings right you grilled that hot
dog you put that hot dog on some [ __ ]
on a bun oh it's gonna taste is It's
[ __ ] amazing
and a hot dog might be the worst you can
no I tell people all the time no you
want to save your kids you want to save
your [ __ ] kids and make your kids
tough you from when they are born to
when they turn three years old give them
nothing but hot dog water
[ __ ] hot dog water that [ __ ]
Robin come on now think about it Robin I
don't know about that your kids
will not take that advice people out
there but JB's kids are very tough they
only have hot dogs
oh